>> Laura: AS THE RACE FOR THE
PRESIDENCY HEATS UP WE THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA TO SEND
OUR OUR OWN RAYMOND ARROYO.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE FOCUSING ON
IN 2020.
>> WE SEEM TO BE ABLE TO HOLD A
CANDLE.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
AND I THINK THERE ARE MORE
QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS.
IT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING.
>> I THINK THEY ARE GETTING IN
EACH OTHER'S WAY.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
SOLIDIFIED PARTY.
NO ONE IS REPRESENTING THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> BUT IS THE ISSUE DRIVING YOUR
VOTE THIS ELECTION SEASON?
WHAT WOULD YOU BE MOST LOOKING
FOR AND AT?
>> I'M A LITTLE SCARED OF
SOCIALISM.
THAT WILL BE A BIG TAKE ON WHY I
VOTE THE WAY I VOTE AND I THINK
THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE RIGHT NOW
IS KIND OF A DISASTER.
>> I MOST FOCUSED ON HOW GREAT
THE ECONOMY IS RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE AN IMMIGRATION PROBLEM
AT THE BORDER THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE SEEM TO BE DENYING.
>> I THINK WE ARE MOVING THE
COUNTRY FORWARD.
THAT'S MOVING THE COUNTRY'S MIND
FROM ECONOMICS TO ALL THE BIG
ISSUES THAT PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING
ABOUT THAT I'M STAYING AWAY
FROM.
>> YOU NEED TO BE A POLITICIAN,
YOU KNOW THAT?